Tyler: Uhhh
Mark: How about now?
Mark: Stream is good.
Tyler: Stream? Yes
Mark: Health is good
Mark: Streaming! Live
Mark: Hello everybody! Hi...
Mark: My name is Markiplier and welcome to the Undertale stream.
Mark: We're starting just a hair early.
Mark: A hair early
Mark: And...
Mark: We are going to be playing Undertale.
Mark: Wait! When did that pop in?
Mark: That popped in late!
Mark: I have no Idea. That's playing audio
Mark: Crap!
Mark: Anyway. Hello!, Hi.
Mark: Welcome to the Undertale-Stream
Mark: This is Tyler.
Tyler: Hello
Mark: Tyler, what do you know about Undertale?
Tyler: Uhhh...
Tyler: There's two different ways to play the game, that I know of.
Mark: hmm
Tyler: The Genocide and then the Passive where you don't kill anything.
Mark: Mhm, but do you know any of the details?
Tyler: There... Two people do voices...
Tyler: ...and there're Sans and other characters?
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: Ok, yeah, that's about what I expected.
Mark: Tyler is um...
Mark: If you guys don't know Tyler
Mark: Like geez...
Mark: Catch up by now.
Mark: He is um...
Mark: He is one of my very good friends
Mark: And we know each other forever
Mark: But the thing about Tyler is that he offers
Mark: Really insightful and interesting opinions on things he knows nothing about.
Mark: Umm...so!
Mark: Hello everybody in chat, yes hello!
Mark: I know, I know, I know. I'm a baby, I'm in my Larva-Form (Babyplier!)
Mark: Don't bother me!
Mark: I wanted to revert back! So,
Mark: The maincharacter in the game is a child.
Mark: Or maybe. I don't know!
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: I think! That's what I think
Tyler: Well, is that what you're channeling?
Mark: Yes, that's what I was going for!
Mark: I..I knew that I was gonna do this
Mark: So I'd have to...
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: If I wanted to really, really embrace
Mark: What Undertale was and what Undertale meant.
Mark: And how Undertale was. (Rambling)
Mark: And how it meant...to me
(Please understand what I mean...)
Mark: And everybody out there. I had to revert back to the ripe age of thirteen.
Mark: So...
Mark: This is uh...
Mark: This is me.
Tyler: Third-Thirdteen?
Mark: Thirdteen
Mark: I looked exactly like this.
Mark: *Laughing* I had this big giant head on my small body
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: My head has been the same exact size since the day I was born, did you know that?
Tyler: I do recall this. I mean the topic of the discussion.
Both: *Laughing*
Mark: I thought you were recalling the day of my birth.
Tyler: Yes! I was there
Mark: Whoa, you were there? *laughing*
Tyler: I was there.
Tyler: And...all of five months old. (Tyler, why)
Mark: Wow...
Mark: Man, that's amazing
Mark: You swam all the way to Hawaii
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: Just to witness my birth. (Who wouldn't?)
Mark: Wait, where were you born?
Tyler: Cincinnati
Mark: Oh, ok yeah. So, swam all the way through...the United States and then the ocean.
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: He's like a Land-Shark, y'know?
Mark: Street-Sharks? Just buried in there and went on.
Mark: This has nothing to do with Undertale.(No?)
Mark: So!
Tyler: Nope.
Mark: What he have here is Undertale.
Mark: Which I know you guys have been dying for...and exploding for...and talking for and waiting for. So
Mark: It's here!
Both: *Dancing*
Both:  *Dancing*
Mark: So, anyway.
Tyler *Laughing*
Mark: About- We're just gonna start in a little bit because people are still getting here
Mark: Um, but
Mark: O-One of the things I wanna preface is
Mark: Yes, I started a Let's Play of this, a while ago
Mark: Yes, I stopped that Let's Play
Mark: And I explained this in the last Livestream that I did, last Thursday
Mark: The reason I stopped it
Mark: Is because
Mark: Number one...
Mark: I ended up not playing it for the reasons I wanted to play it
Mark: And it was-it became this thing where
Mark: Everyone was disappointed in the way I was playing it
Mark: And ordinarily I would just be like:
Mark: "Y'know, I'm doing it my way. I'm gonna-I'm gonna this."
Mark: But unfortunately
Mark: It was so pervasive
Mark: That it made the entire experience not fun for me.
Mark: It was literally just a moment where I was like:
Mark: "I'm not having fun making these videos because I know
Mark: That no matter what I do, everyone will think I'm wrong." You know?
Mark: So I couldn't go into it with an open mind
Mark: And I couldn't go into it with an open heart!
Mark: And everyone had spoiled it already because of the choices that I'd made
Mark: In the beginning everyone was like:
Mark: "No you're doing it wrong! You need to do it this way!
Mark: You need to do this thing! You have to play it!
Mark: And that defeats the entire purpose of what Undertale was
Tyler: Mhm
Mark: Because Undertale is a game that's meant to be explored in whatever way you want
Mark: Now that doesn't mean, that there aren't just two endings, which there are
Mark: And-there are three technically
Mark: There's like the middle of the road and one.
Mark: The whole experience is about like...
Mark: Enjoying the world
Mark: And meeting these characters and like deciding what to do when you see them
Tyler: Just like any other RPG kinda suppose to do your own thing.
Mark: Yeah exactly!
Mark: Yeah you're suppose to-it's-you're suppose to be the person
Mark: and like, that's why this character, I believe, is such a blank slate
Mark: Like this kid has no expressions, no emotions
Mark: Because the blanker the slate, the easier it is for you to put your eyes in your, your, your, your...perspective
Mark: In their shoes, you know?
Mark: To step in.
Mark: And become that person
Mark: So uh-
Tyler: Your own personality and character development
Mark: So when it came to a game like this and everyone was just like:
Mark: "Oh no! You have to do it this way!
Mark: Your voices aren't right
Mark: Like, we have the right voices!"
Mark: And it's like:
Mark: "No, I'm not gonna do that."
Mark: You know? It's just one of those moments where I'm like:
Mark: "I'm gonna-I'm gonna do it my way"
Mark: That's what this is all about
Mark: If you expect anything to be like catering to
Mark: The way...it's expected to be played
Mark: I don't know if I'm gonna do that.
Mark: I-I-I have a certain way that I default to playing which is uhh...
Mark: Going very calm and cautiously towards these types of games and exploring
Mark: A-a-and digging  up all the the little bitty details about it
Mark: but that doesn't mean, that I'll make every choice the way people want me to make it
Mark: And that's why Tyler is here!
Mark: If you're wondering why Tyler is here
Mark: It's because Tyler is like the voice of reason.
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: And uhh
Mark: Normally I'm-I'm. I'm a more brash individual but he's calm
Mark: And thinks about things very carefully
Mark: So he's going to be helping me through this experience
Mark: And also we're going to be talking about the game as we go by
Mark: Because, oddly enough
Mark: It's been about over a year since this game was first released
Mark: And I don't know everything in the game
Mark: Because I've managed to dodge. Everytime Undertale was mentioned I just dab out of the way
Mark: Just like: "Whoops! Ok! That's not gonna be for me"
Mark: And then uh, you know, I just do
Mark: My thing there and hopefully
Mark: Hopefully, we're gonna have some surprises on the way
Mark: Because he knows nothing! Like he's never played the game
Mark: Have you watched anyone play the game?
Tyler: Nope
Mark: Nope. Yeah, so he has never seen the game before so it'll be an entirely new experience for him
Mark: So! If you're all ready
Mark: And I believe that most of the people are here, that are going to be here
Mark: So let's get started on the adventure!
Mark: What do I do? (great start)
Mark: Bam!
Mark: There we go!
Mark: Pick a name!
Mark: What's the name of this young, fallen human
Mark: Doesn't even say child, it's just a human
Tyler: Human
Tyler: Ok
Tyler: So I have to-I have to give it a name?
Mark: Oh, I thought that was the name!
Both: H U M A N
Tyler: So H-U-E-M-A-N
Both *laughing*
Mark: His name is Hu-
Mark: Is that how you spell Hue?
Mark: oh man, can you even put a space in here?
Tyler: I don't-uhh
Mark: We can do a better name than that
Tyler: yeah, yeah
Mark: Alright, what do you got?
Tyler: Do you remember Spore with my names?
Tyler: How uncreative they were?
Mark: I remember my names. I don't know if they were the same as your names.
Tyler: Mine were like 'Spikey'!
Both: *Laughing*
Mark: Well, mine were the  Chualimilly (WTF Mark?!)
Mark: Why am I alive?
Mark: Oh, we should play Spore again for a future Livestream
Mark: But we don't need that, we need something else here.
Mark: A legit name.
Mark: Humangus
Tyler Humangus
Both: Laughing
Mark: Humangus what?
Mark: Have you ever seen that?
Tyler: No.
Mark: No?!
Mark: Ah man, it'd just make you angry
Mark: It's ok
Tyler: Ok
Mark: We'll watch it later
Mark: Anyway so eh...
Mark: So what should we call him?
Mark: Ohhh, we should call him Peepo
Tyler: Ohhhh
Mark: We should call him Peepo
Mark: That was chat there
Mark: Chat well-
Mark: Pfpo
Tyler: Pfeepo
Mark: Peeeeeee
Mark: pooo
Mark: Alright
Mark: I-I think this is good enough. Peepo!
Tyler: I like it
Mark: "Is-Is this name correct?"
Mark: Well, now that you're...now that you're making it bigger like that, I'm not 100% sure but let's go
Tyler: Why is it shaking at us?
Mark: It's nervous
Mark: It's his first time
Tyler: It's a nervous Peepo
Mark: Yeah, and also we're starting over from the beginning here because
Mark: I wanted a fresh experience out of this, not tainted by like the previous Let's Play that I did. So!
Mark: This is Peepo!
Mark: This is Peepo's adventure
Tyler: See, I even thought that this whole game was in black and white, so
Mark: You did?
Tyler: Yeah.
Mark: Hey, look at that!
Tyler: It's a flower (It is?)
Mark: "Howdy! I'm Flowey"
Mark: "Flowey the Flower!"
Both: "Hmm..."
Both *Laughing*
Mark: "You're new to the Underground, aren'tcha?
Mark: "Golly!" *Laughing*
Tyler: Underground was a place like back in Ohio where there'd be Battle of the Bands summoned, they said and I was like:
Tyler: "Is there gonna be..."
Mark: All of the sudden, bands are gonna come out of the darkness and just gonna play some sick rhythms
Mark: "Golly, you must be so confused"
Mark: "Someone ought to teach you how things work around here"
Mark: "I guess little old me will have to do"
Mark: "Ready? Here we go!"
Mark: I'll let you take over for this
Mark: Because I already know how to play!
Mark: "That is your soul, the very culmination of your being!"
Tyler: What do I hit?
Mark: Why'd you click outside of the game?
Mark: Don't do the mouse!
Tyler: Ok! What do I hit?
Mark: The arrow-keys
Mark: See, you can move around
Tyler: Ok
Mark: "Your soul starts off weak, but can grow strong if you gain alot of LV"
Tyler: Lvvllv
Tyler: Love. LV doesn't stand for love
Mark: No, in this universe it does stand for love
Tyler: Ok
Mark: "You want some love, don't you?"
Tyler: Is it gonna give me a hug? (Sure he will)
Mark: Well, I mean it doesn't have any arms so I don't know how
Tyler: "I'll share some with you"
Mark: Share some love
Tyler: I don't like that face!
Mark: Here comes the love!
Mark: "Little white friendliness pellets!"
Mark: Are you ready?
Tyler: Umm
Mark: "Get as many as you can!"
Tyler: Wait...
Both: *Laughing*
Tyler: Went the wrong way!
Mark: "Hey buddy, you missed them"
Tyler: Wait, why does it look angry at me now?
Mark: It's not angry, what'r you talking- Let's try again
Tyler: Oh
Tyler: Wait, what happened?
Mark: "You idiot"
Tyler: Oh, now it's evil!
Mark: Yeah
Tyler: That's evil
Mark: "In this world, it's kill or be killed"
Tyler: But-
Mark: "Why would anyone pass up an opportunity like this?"
Mark: Muhahahaha
Tyler: Uhh
Mark: Muhimumya mihumuamua
Die
Tyler: Well, apparently white pellets aren't love.
Mark: Yeah. You screwed up, ya idiot
Tyler: Ok
Mark: Oh, but wait.
Tyler: That was fire
Tyler: And it's a Goat-Lady!
Mark: Yup, that's pretty much what it is.
Both: *Laughing*
Mark: "What a terrible creature, torturing such a poor, innocent youth..."
Mark: "Ah, do not be afraid, my child."
Mark: "I'm, Toriel, caretaker of the Ruins."
Mark: "I pass through this place every once- everyday to see if anybody has fallen down."
Tyler: Every once in a while. *Laughing*
Mark: Shut up!
Mark: I'm reading unless you wanna start reading and I don't think you wanna narrate this.
Tyler: No
Mark: "You're the first human to come down here in a long time."
Mark: "Come! I will guide you through the catacombs."
Tyler: I'm just
Mark: No! Give me that, you're done
Tyler: Ok
Mark: You screwed up! You screwed it up
Mark: "This way."
Mark: Ah yes
Tyler That's good, 'cause I was playing left-handed and it felt really weird *Laughing*
Mark: So what do you-so what conclusion did you just draw from that first encounter with Flowey
Tyler: That apparently he wants to kill you
Mark: Yes, he sure does
Tyler: And flowerseeds are bad
Mark: Friendliness pellets are bad
Tyler: Ok
Mark: I don't think that was-I don't think Flowey was shooting you with his seed
Mark: Cause that just sounds horrifying
Mark: "The shadow of the Ruins looms above, filling you with determination"
Mark: "HP fully restored"
Mark: So we're gonna save. We did it. Game over. Good Job
Tyler: I don't trust you right now
Both: *laughing*
Tyler: You told me to collect the pellets too!
Mark: I didn't tell you to do anything! (Sure you didn't)
Mark: I was narrating. I was leading you to draw your own conclusions out of it
Mark: Cause that's what it's all about, drawing your own conclusions out of it
Tyler: There, there
Mark: "Welcome to your new home, innocent one."
Mark: Allow me to educate you in the operation of the Ruins."
Mark: See, it's that simple
Tyler: It's a puzzle pattern!
Mark: "Yes, the Ruins are full of puzzles."
Mark: "Ancient fusions between diversions and doorkeys."
Mark: "One musst solve them to move from room to room."
Mark: "Please adjust yourself to the sight of them."
Tyler: *laughing*
Mark: Oh man...
Tyler: This already makes me think kind of cause Zelda had alot of puzzles to get from room to room and so
Mark: Yes indeed, actually this game drew alot of inspiration from some old-school RPG's
Mark: Most notably I think Earthbound?
Mark: Was the one it really drew alot of inspiration from
Mark: Did you ever play Earthbound?
Tyler: Nope
Mark: Ok. "Don't worry, I've labelled the ones you need to flip
Mark: "Press [z] to read signs."
Mark: Oh that's so nice
Mark: "Stay on the path."
Mark: Ok, so when-when  was I first playing, people thought there were like lots and lots and lots of secrets and stuff
Mark: And uhh...*Marki-Noise*
Mark: "No no no! You want to press the other switch!
Mark: "I even labelled it for you."
Tyler: What happenes if you hit the wrong one?
Mark: It won't let you, like especially in this beginning area
Mark: You'd think there'd be alot of ways to navigate through and alot of different things
Mark: It's pretty linear
Mark: Like on the way that it is
Tyler: I wanted to see what happens if you end up picking the wrong thing, so
Mark: Well, that's what I wanted to see too! That's another thing when I first played this game
Mark: I wanted to see all the choices at once because that's how I play games
Tyler: Yeah
Mark: I wanna see where the path leads before I take my choice
Mark: But in this game, if you do something, you're commited to it
Tyler: Mhh
Mark: You can't go back
Mark: You literally can't go back because it's logged into a savefile beforehand
Mark: And it'll like call you out on your bullshit
Mark: If you try to go back and do something
Tyler: Oh-oh
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: "However worry not! The process is simple."
Mark: "When you encounter a monster, you will enter a fight."
Mark: "While you're in a fight, strike up a friendly conversation!"
Mark: "Stall for time. I will come to resolve the conflict
Mark: "Practise talking to the dummy."
Mark: So!
Tyler: Is this why you're here? I'm here to hear you practise talking-nevermind
Mark: Yes, I need alot of practise I'm horribly alone
Mark: Ok, so you encountered a dummy, what should we do?
Tyler: Call it a dummy?
Mark: That's really harsh, I don't know if we can
Mark: Dummy, talk to him
Mark: "You talk to the Dummy. It doesn't seem much for conversation."
Mark: Probably because it's a burlap sack over some fluff
Mark: "Toriel seems happy with you."
Mark: You-we win! Good job, dude!
Tyler: That was an easy win.
Mark: I know right?
Mark: "Ah, very good! You're very good!"
Mark: Even though you wanted to insult it!
Mark: I mean, technically I believe it's kinda the same similarity thing, it wouldn't know either way
Tyler: Yeah
Mark: "There's another puzzle in this room."
Mark: "I wonder if you can solve it."
Tyler: I see grass on the wall
Mark: Congratulations you doof
Mark: Oh-Oh!
Mark: "Froggit attacks you."
Mark: What do we do?
Tyler: What is Act?
Tyler: Are we acting like something?
Tyler: I like that one.
Mark: Ok
Tyler: What is Check?
Mark: Check, just look at it
Mark: "Life is d"- ouu!
Tyler: Ohh, I feel bad for it now
Mark: I also just noticed: It has eyes underneath it.
Tyler: Oh, Oh my ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mark: And eyes above it
Mark: Eh, whatever
Tyler: I don't see pupils in those eyes
Mark: Yeah, *weird engine-noise*
Mark: You won
Tyler: We're getting zero xp and gold
Mark: That's a good thing to observe
Mark: Because in this game there's ways to win
Mark: You can fight
Mark: Or you can act
Mark: Get it?
Tyler: Yes
Mark: Ok, fast-learner this guy!
Mark: "The western room..."
Tyler: Exept acting to me seems like I'm acting like I'm somebody else like
Tyler: Actually like an actor
Mark: No, it's just like-it's an action, it stands for action not acting
Tyler: Ok, there, there
Mark: "This is the puzzle, but. Here take my hand for a moment."
Mark: Awww
Mark: She's so sweet
Mark: Take it, if you go the wrong way you actually hit spikes.
Mark: Yeah, and die horribly (thats a lie)
Mark: Game over (Again, thats a lie)
Mark: Aw she's so sweet. "Puzzles seem a little too dangerous for now
Mark: "You have done excellently thus far"
Mark: Good Job, Tyler!
Mark: Up top!
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: Alright, one more
Mark: *Laughing*
Tyler: Dammit
*Laughing*
Mark: Alright, for real this time!
Tyler: I don't trust you now!
Mark: There you go, that's the right attitude
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: Alright, ok
Mark: "I would like you to walk to the end of the room by yourself."
Mark: "Forgive me for this!"
Mark: Oh-Oh!
*dramatic music*
Mark: Run home
*Dancing again*
Tyler: *Laughing*
Mark: Alright, the weirdest thing was!
Tyler: This is a long room
Mark: The weirdest thing was: You and I were in sync in real life
Tyler: But not on camera
Mark: But on camera we were completely off
Tyler: I saw that!
Mark: How the hell did that work?
Tyler: I don't know. I guess 'cause the angle?
Mark: I don't know, that was bizarre
Tyler: 'Cause I was looking at it too and I'm like
Mark: Yeah, that's
Tyler: I totally see, I was moving at the same time
Mark: And then I was looking over and I'm like: We're doing the same
Mark: This is bizarre
Mark: Ok. "Do not leave-do not worry, I did not leave you"
Mark: "I was merely behind this pillar the whole time."
Mark: Ain't that sweet?
Tyler: Can you hide behind the pillar?
Mark: I cannot
Tyler: Dammit
Mark: "Thank you for trusting me"
Mark: "However, there was an important reason for this exercise"
Mark: "To test your independence"
Mark: "I must attend to some business, and you must stay alone for a while"
Mark: "Please remain here. It's dangerous to explore by yourself"
Mark: "I have an idea. I will give you a cell phone"
Tyler: Ok
Mark: Oh cool, alright then
Tyler: *laughing*
Mark: "If you have the need for anything just call"
Mark: "Be good, alright?"
Mark: Maybe I can hide behind the pillar
Tyler: No? No
Mark: Well, apparently not
Mark: I never even thought about that
Tyler: I don't believe you go -you lied! You can hide behind there!
Mark: You don't like the goat?
Tyler: No, I like the goat but the goat is weird
Mark: Oh yeah, a little weird
Mark: "Hello, this is Toriel. You have not left the room, have you?"
Mark: Uhh Oh no jeez, oh gosh
Mark: "There are a few puzzles ahead, that I have yet to explain."
Mark: "It would be dangerous to try to solve them yourself."
Mark: "Be good, alright?
Mark: *Click*
Mark: I-I used Toriel as a good excuse to talk in the head voice and save my-not get vocal fryyyyyy
Tyler: Are we gonna teach about vocal fryyy
Mark: I don't think we need to talk about vocal fryy
Tyler: Vocal fryy
Mark: Vocal fryy
Mark: Alright, excuse me
Mark: "I have some advise for you about battling monsters"
Mark: "If you act a certain way, or fight until you almost defeat them"
Mark: "They might not want to battle you anymore"
Mark: "If a monster does not want to fight you, please..."
Mark: "Use some mercy, human. Ribbit"
Tyler: Throwing in Overwatch-characters
Mark: Well there you have it
Mark: No
Tyler: Ok
Mark: Believe it or not, this game came out before Overwatch
Tyler: Well, I mean that makes sense since you said, it came out a year ago
Mark: That is true
Mark: Uh-Oh
Mark: Froggit
Mark: That bastard Froggit standing on the top of the thing and freaking attacks you
Tyler: He just talked to you and came-
Tyler: Sneak-Attack!
Mark: Alright, what should we do?
Mark: Should we teach him a lesson?
Tyler: Didn't he have this terrible life when we already inspected him?
Tyler: So
Mark: Possibly
Tyler: I-I'd feel bad. I-
Mark: You wanna threaten him?
Tyler: No
Mark: Get your life together, you piece of shit! (I would if I could)
Tyler: No, I-
Mark: You little sack of crap!
Tyler: I-if he's having a hard time, you compliment people that have a hard time.
Mark: Aww, that's so sweet!
Mark: He didn't know what you said
Tyler: But was flattered anyway.
Mark: Oh, he's-
*laughing*
Tyler: "I don't know what you're saying, but it sounds nice!"
Mark: Ok, now do you remember this part?
Tyler: Uhh
Mark: *Dying Frog-noise*
Mark: *Another dying Frog-noise*
Mark: See, that's the whole part of this game
Tyler: That's the fighting part of the game
Mark: When they attack you
Mark: They don't just like *wapish* do damage
Mark: It's always that thing
Mark: See, that's why the Flowey-fight was so important!
Tyler: So, you have to dodge
Mark: Yeah, exactly
Mark: So, if you wanna survive on compliments alone you have to...dodge these attacks
Tyler: Be really good at dodging
Mark: Yeah, and once you get to a certain point, you can try to have mercy on them or you can fight and kill them!
Mark: Like that's another option
Mark: Which would you rather do?
Mark: Oh he doesn't wanna fight
Tyler: It depends on the character
Mark: Exactly, right?
Tyler: If they're mean people, I'd wanna take them down if they're doing bad things.
Mark: So like, we'll make a commitment until we see someone doing bad
Mark: We'll be nice!
Tyler: Ok, I like that
Mark: We'll lay down the law
Mark: Lay down!
Tyler: Yeah
Tyler: We've got the guns to handle the bad guys
Mark: *Fighting noises?*
Mark: Ok, anyway
Mark: Alright, so what was up here?
Mark: Oh yeah
Mark: What is this?
Tyler: Although in Mass Effect I like being the mercenary
Tyler: So I was like neutral the whole time
Mark: Oh yeah
Tyler: That was fun
Mark: I though you didn't play Mass Effect?
Tyler: I played it once and I was trying to do the neutral thing and it was difficult
Mark: Nah, I was all Paragon, I was super Paragon
Mark: I don't remember this candy
Tyler: I think Wade was super Paragon too
Mark: Yeah. I mean I played both. I did every single thing that you could do in the entire game
Mark: And it was just like, it's super cool
Mark: "Take one. Take a candy?" We've already taken a candy
Mark: Should we take another?
Tyler: It's still there, I mean. When it said 'Take one' on Halloween, I took hand fulls
Mark: That is true
Mark: I'll take another
Mark: "You took more candy. How dis-"*laughing*
Mark: Oops!
Mark: Uh-Oh
Mark: We've ruined the pacifist ending!
Mark: *While laughing* "You feel like the scum of the earth"
Mark: I don't, do you feel like the scum of the earth?
Tyler: No, I feel like, I'm getting more candy!
Mark: "You took too much-" Ohh noo
Tyler: That's-
Mark: Oh what have I done?
Mark: "Look at what you've done."
*laughing*
Mark: Oh no, I've ruined everything
Mark: The only option now is to kill everybody who saw this!
*laughing*
Mark: We must murder everybody
Tyler: Wait, why!
Mark: They'll see what we've done!
Tyler: How? This is a little room!
Mark: No! They'll come by. Every monster wants a piece of candy, this is the only free bowl of candy
Mark: In the entire monster world!
Mark: They'll see! We have to murder everybody!
Tyler: I don't believe you!
Mark: Ok, good. There you go, that's the right strategy
*laughing*
Mark: Oh gee
Tyler: Why do you keep looking at the same place?
Mark: That's a save. It's a save
Tyler: Oh, ok
Mark: Thanks man, thanks for not believing in me
Mark: Whoa shoot!
Mark: Alright. Just go away!
Mark: Go. Get out of here!
Mark: Wha
Tyler: What the-. What? What?
Mark: He's got different attacks, dude
Tyler: Oh
Mark: Errr
Mark: It was an angry compliment
Tyler: Yeah. Beef! Beef- *laughing*
Tyler: An angry compliment
Tyler: You're too nice
Tyler: Why are you here?
Mark: I don't know
Tyler: Is that the angry compliment?
Tyler: That wasn't even complimenting but ok
Mark: I have no idea
Tyler No, I did! "You're too nice"
Tyler: That's a compliment
Mark: Oh, oh is it?
Tyler: I guess. Is that a compliment, chat?
Mark: Oh, I have no idea
Tyler: Chat, is saying "You're too nice" a compliment?
Mark: Chat! Chat, come on, chat
Mark: Chat, ahhhh!
Tyler: Uhh
Mark: What happened?
Tyler: I have no clue
Mark: We fell down, that's what happened
Tyler: Through a hole? (No, through a triangle)
Mark: Yeah, through a hole
Mark: In the floor
Tyler: I wasn't looking, I was looking at chat so it was really confused *Laughing*
Mark: Well you keep an eye on chat, I'll keep reading
Mark: "Hello. This is Toriel."
Mark: "For no reason in particular...whch do you prefer?"
Mark: "Cinnamon or Butterscotch?"
Mark: What do you-what do you- what do you like?
Tyler: I like cinnamon
Mark: Yeah, me too
Mark: Ah, no actually I like butterscotch alot
Mark: I like cinnamon, like I used to. You know those atomic fireballs?
Mark: Aha
Tyler: That was my favorite candy as a kid. I'd suck on those until my mouth just like *weird sound*
Mark: We'll do cinnamon. "Oh I see. Thank you very much."
Mark: "Click"
Mark: Oh?
Mark: "Hello. This is Toriel"
Mark: "You do not dislike butterscotch, do you?"
Mark: Do you?
`Tyler: I mean it depends on what kind
Tyler: I can deal with butterscotch
Mark: "I know what your preference is, but..."
Mark: "Would you turn up your nose if you found it on your plate?"
Tyler: No, I'm never rude
Mark: Oh
Tyler: If I'm giving something, I'm generally very thankful
Tyler: Even if I don't like it, I'll try it anyway
Mark: That's nice, you're never gonna survive in this world
Mark: You're gonna be-you're gonna be like-your corpse is gonna be riddled with bullets and stab wounds
Mark: In the gutter in the monster world
Mark: See me, I know how to live
Mark: You gotta kill everybody, you see
*laughing*
Mark: You gotta riddle people with bullets and stab 'em and dump them in the gutter before they kill you
Tyler: My god
Mark: Its true!